there are new outtakes from the set of
that movie that Alec Baldwin worked on
where he shot and killed that woman the
cinematographer there are outtakes that
seem to show that Baldwin was in fact
concerned about some of the safety
measures or lack thereof on the set and
everyone need to be right here like in
the path of the gun could you please
move just want to be over him a little
bit so I can see now wait a second if
I'm going to shoot right you want to go
on the other side of the camera I don't
want to shoot toward you apparently they
continued in this Reckless way anyway on
the set and here's a really unpopular
opinion it's not Baldwin's fault Alec
Baldwin is not responsible for the
shooting on the rust set I know
instantly what people are going to say
is if you have a firearm it is always
your responsibility what happens with
that firearm if you have a firearm and
you're pointing it at someone then you
need to be ready to destroy whatever
you're pointing at that's basic firearm
safety 101 and that's all true but
that's not movie making 101 if you're
using a gun in a movie it almost always
involves you pointing it and shooting it
at somebody it is not comparable